mesdames et messieurs effectivement
bonjour merci château de bogard
donc ici pour le week-end du 14 juin la
mise en place toutes sortes d'activités
un petit air révolutionnaire souffle sur
le château de beauregard pour la fête
nationale
le visiteur devient citoyen ateliers
d'écriture et de dessin sur le thème de
la liberté
découverte de la symbolique du drapeau
tricolore le public peut même faire sa
carte d'identité selon le calendrier
républicain j'ai déterminé ma date de
naissance révolutionnaire et je suis
donc née le jour du chiendent de l'an
185 je préfère le 11 février 1977 est un
épisode de l'histoire de france qui
détonne dans ce lieu où la royauté à la
part belle comme en témoigne la pièce
maîtresse du château la galerie des
portraits 327 visage 15 règne
représenter de philippe 6 à louis xiii
on a plus de 300 ans d'histoire et on se
demande bien pourquoi on fête le 14
juillet parce que le 14 mai c'est quand
même une date symbolique
voilà il faut savoir quand même que les
4 en juillet c'est la prise de la
bastille effectivement on retient sa de
1789 le 14 juillet voilà sauf qu'on est
encore dans la royauté à ce moment là on
est pas on n'est pas passé en république
voilà donc finalement c'est pas si
paradoxal que ça une manière de proposer
aux visiteurs une plongée dans
l'histoire
toute l'histoire de france